Pirates are still a thing if you put all
the pirate incidents on a map over the
last 40 years it looks like this there
are thousands and thousands of dots over
in Indonesia you've got Pirates
hijacking cargo ships in the Strait of
Malacca in Nigeria Pirates are stealing
oil from these huge tankers and like
selling it on the black market the big
hot spot in all of this was Somalia
where the government wasn't really
around because it was busy fracturing
and fighting a Civil War and so these
Coastal communities just started to be
Pirates to make a living and they made
millions and millions of dollars per
Ransom and they did hundreds of ransoms
a year yeah it's not Blackbeard and Jack
Sparrow anymore but it's kind of the
same thing young dudes who don't have
much to do who are in a dire economic
situation going into the chaos of the
high seas
to try to make money and running
sophisticated businesses piracy and it
still exists